et on continue à en parler avec alain
rodier il est ancien officier supérieur
au sein des services de renseignement
français mais également directeur
adjoint du lycée fr cf2r c'est le centre
français de recherche sur le
renseignement
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pour bien comprendre
que reprochent précisément les états
unis à la russie dans le cadre de ce
traité
eh bien il reproche l'interdiction de
survol de trois zones je dirais surtout
celle de kaliningrad ou la russie aurait
déployé des missiles de nucléaire depuis
des années mais les avions de
surveillance n'ont pas le droit
d'approcher de cette zone d'à +2 à moins
de 500 km et il lui est également juge j
les deux républiques indépendantes qui
ne ne doivent pas être survolées alors
voilà le le le hiatus je dirais qu'ils
existent avec des états unis à l'heure
actuelle alors comment interpréter un ce
retrait de washington qui accuse on
vient de le dire moscou de violer ce
traité bon dessus alors c'est
extrêmement compliqué bien sûr sur le
plan renseignements sait pas grand chose
parce que depuis que les satellites
d'observation existe il est évident que
les vols d'observation photographe pays
kral ou même radar pour ne servent plus
techniquement à grand chose
mais sur le plan politique c'est
extrêmement important
et tant que ce retrait des américains
s'inscrit effectivement dans lé retrait
de 10,2 différents traités c'est le
troisième maintenant qu'ils sont
rassurants ces retraits sont extrêmement
inquiétant bon pour les partenaires des
états unis dans le traité
ben spies cela également est gênant
parce qu'il ya un certain nombre de pays
ne bénéficient pas des reconnaissances
aériennes de satellites etc et donc
profiter jusqu'à maintenant de l'apport
donnée par cette possibilité pour
s'informer eux-mêmes et c'est pour cela
qu'un certain nombre de pays européens
une dizaine à l'heure actuelle et bien
ne participe pas aux réticences
américaines
du coup maintenant quelles conséquences
pourrait-il y avoir sur l'europe ont
pour le moment il y a effectivement une
mésentente en euros entre l'euro et
washington puisque dix pays ont bien
déclaré qu'il ne participait pas à le
retrait unilatéral des états unis ont ce
retrait ne sera effectif que dans six
mois comme cela a été souligné par les
correspondants précédents
donc il faut attendre washington 10 est
prêt à négocier des des points de détail
bon c'est d'avoir donc il est évident
que dans les cadres techniques de cette
surveillance les soldes avion qui
survolait les états unis pour
photographier ou vérifier les
installations américaines mais c'était
des avions russes et bon inversement
c'était un petit peu différent mais donc
comme je le disais précédemment
techniquement c'est pas vraiment quelque
chose d'extrêmement important mais
politiquement c'est un signe très fort
justement politiquement jusqu'à quel
niveau on peut imaginer de nouvelles
tensions avec la russie
ab les tensions sont toujours exacerbés
les forces de l'otan et des
et ruelles se se fritent si vous me
permettez l'expression
bon la crise du coronavirus avait
interrompu des grandes manoeuvres de
l'otan'' qui était prévu en europe de
l'ouest comme on l'appelait précédemment
et avait interrompu également les
manoeuvres en défense armée russe qui
venait en contrebalancer je dirais c'est
ses opérations militaires
mais cela dit cela ne veut pas dire que
cela va pas repartir de plus belle mais
on cite assez assez peu un un sujet
crucial qui est principal pour les états
unis mais également pour la russie c'est
la chine parce que je rappelle que la
chine n'est signataire
d'aucuns non d'accord ni opensky ni les
autres et en particulier sur le traité
des missiles intermédiaires qui a été
rompue donc par les états unis
le grand problème c'est que les chinois
ne l'ont jamais signer quoi que ce soit
dans ce domaine et donc qu'il y avait un
problème de balance seul j'irais en
extrême orient extrêmement important à
la fois les états unis mais soulignons
le à la fois pour la russie alors on le
disait à une renégociation n'est pas
exclue par les états unis dans quelles
conditions selon vous bombay il est
évident qu'il va avoir les tractations
de coulisses jeu tout le monde sait très
bien que donald trump est en campagne
électorale pour sa réélection qui est à
l'heure actuelle semble acquis ce dont
je suis pas un politologue avisé donc je
ne peux pas être certain de jugement
mais il semble que ça va se passer
correctement
cela dit ce qui m'inquiète un petit peu
c'est qu'il vient de désigner un nouveau
chef du renseignement qui couvre les 17
agences de renseignement
américaine qui est un ultraconservateur
donc sont ils à un virage vraiment je
dirais vers les néoconservateurs vous
voulez l'ultra conservateur qui est peut
être extrêmement inquiète
merci beaucoup alain rodier d'avoir
partagé votre expertise je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien officier supérieur au
sein des services de renseignement
français
ah mais également directeur-adjoint du
cf2r